[Music]
well you want fireworks there are plenty
and Tom Cruise's new trailer The Mummy I
mean the action is crazy the stunts are
out of control but what is the most
special effect of all or our curly steel
it seems to be Tom's hot bod you turn
the Morrigan to Magic Mike
the only what it's like turn that into
betcha there was a one scene that film
where instead of the women the audience
weren't going through they were going
more like ah you came up with that idea
right after the plane crash
that'd be funny for that plane crash Tom
went zero gravity in a real plane 64
drops to shoot the scene is there ever a
moment for your life this is a lot kind
of your users luckily I didn't get sick
I mean I got to do these tanks I've
convinced everyone to do this I can't be
sitting in the corner going please tap
out you know I can't tap out Tom plays
Nick who makes a big mistake by removing
the Mummy's casket it's a very different
role for you this one he's a funny guy
thief bit of a scallywag who finds his
humanity at the end we don't want to
give away the ending something else Tom
it's not giving away Top Gun two secrets
will there be female fighter pilots in
the cockpit yeah look I can't talk about
the story at all at this point
buddies there's no I can't I can't say
anything but I'm very excited about it
well you can't blame a girl for trying
[Music]
you